these are the lucky ones the weary
people who have escaped ukraine and
arrived in poland
more come through this crossing all the
time the border guards tell us that on
the ukrainian side the queue of cars now
stretches for 25 miles they expect some
people to have to wait for two and a
half days
but many are getting here on foot
we meet ola she and her sister together
with their five children had just
arrived after an arduous journey from
the ukrainian city of levith
at the beginning we drove a car and then
we had to walk on foot for 20 kilometers
it was hard we're not making plans at
this point we fled because it was too
scary there
there are happy reunions ripples of
relief but there's also real fear and
anger
nobody who's here
wants to be here
this is not an exodus of all ukrainians
because just about everyone coming
through this border crossing is either a
woman or a child men aged between 18 and
60 have been told to stay over there in
ukraine and fight for their country
and the more that people arrive the more
you get that sense of desperation this
feels less like a border crossing a more
like a refugee camp
seven miles away and this is the nearest
train station to the border it is very
busy and there's an emergency shelter
for new arrivals
what strikes you is that people are
arriving with almost nothing
tanya was sheltering with her children
in a basement until she fled
my husband say you need to save our
children you need to go
because if you will stay in downstairs
in not safety
poland has offered to welcome every
ukrainian who wants to come even if that
figure runs into millions
but this country is seething at what it
sees as europe's slow mega response and
one of its leading political figures
told me the culprits included europe's
richest nation
it's a great disappointment that
particular interests of certain
countries such as germany
are more important than moral
obligations when it comes to helping
ukrainians and punishing russians
because russians today act as bandits
you see the kindness of volunteers here
the acts of generosity it briefly
beguiles
and then you remember what's causing
this
war in europe
now
adam parsons sky news on the poland
ukraine border